ta parole est maintenant monsieur serge
dassault pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président monsieur unis
chers collègues à propos des dépenses
publiques que 2013 vous fais remarquer
que dans la situation financière
critique où nous sommes
une autre façon c'est loin d'être
assurée les recettes budgétaires sont
très optimistes
vous alimentez impôts pour financer les
dépenses nouvelles qui ne sont pas
nécessaires et pour satisfaire vos
électeurs de plus on augmente on dépense
nous alerter les agences de notation
dont on oublie la glissance qui sont pas
loin de nous et qui nous ont mis sous
haute surveillance car il fait le
contraire de ce qu'ils ont proposé de ce
qu'il faudra faire c'est à dire baisser
les dépenses baisser les recettes et non
pas les augmenter
car une fois que notre note sera
dégradée notturno tenir et augmenter ni
toit plus emprunter les 160 milliards
annuels
sauf à des taux d'intérêt est énorme la
france comme la grèce l'espagne sera en
cessation de paiement le risque est
énorme et il est pas normal de l'assumer
la croissance est faible car elle
provient la production et l'exportation
trop réduit et même de l'euro qui doit
être dévalué ce qu'on ne fait pas car
trop fort par rapport à $ et qui réduit
notre compétitivité et 35 heures que
vous refusez elle vous coûtent 21
milliards par an c'est quand même pas
rien sur le plan militaire et accorde
des allègements de charges et augmenter
nos coûts de production qui ont trahi
passé cet enfant ce contrat est le moins
est anormal que le rapport gallois
d'ailleurs n'en tiennent aucun compte
quant à l'essai fait plus value que vous
augmentez vous décourager les créateurs
d'entreprises les investisseurs qui
préfèrent partir que père leur
patrimoine ils investissent dorénavant
en angleterre en belgique et plus
enfants ce qui crée et accroît le
chômage en france pour réduire les
dépenses il faut commencer par ne pas
les augmenter
et vouloir couvrir ses dépenses aux
augmentations d'impôts est une grave
erreur qui ne peut qu'aggraver le
chômage alors qu on était tellement plus
facile de ne pas embaucher 60 mille
fonctionnaires que vous devrez payer 60
ans n'oubliez pas pas dans cinq ans 60
ans parce qu'ils vont encore durer 400
plus la retraite et cetera de ne pas
augmenter le smig de ne pas augmenter la
question d'entrer scolaire tout ça c'est
des cadeaux ne pas dire à l'autre est à
60 ans ce qui est pas nécessaire de ne
pas créer des emplois d'avenir non
marchand qui ne sert à rien et vous
maintenez des dépenses fiscales
they de l'emploi de 10 milliards 2,3
milliards d'exonérations ciblés etc
je pense que l'urgence absolue de ne pas
voir diminuer notre notation et
augmenter notre taux d'intérêt et il
faudrait tout faire pour cela
ensemble à solidarité nationale et
surtout m'attire le déficit 2013 à 3% et
pas plus car son la nuque ne me
comprends pas c'est pourquoi je voulais
vous demander si vous avez conscience de
ce risque
si vous abandonnerez un jour vos
décisions idéologiques comme les 35
heures et des ff pour adopter celle plus
réaliste qui permettront sol de
redresser la france offre un cadre
d'union nationale merci chers collègues
la parole est aux ministres
et si monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur et ayant toujours plus
difficile de répondre en reproches qu'il
n'en faut pour le formuler mais j'ai
néanmoins essayé de me répondre de la
manière la plus précise possible sur le
risque que vous évoquez de voir les taux
d'intérêt montent et pour notre pays
c'est un risque auquel nous sommes
extrêmement sensibles comme vous nous
faisons tous d'ailleurs pour tenter de
l'éviter je constate pour l'instant avec
un certain succès puisque et taux
d'intérêt auxquels le pays emprunte
n'ont jamais été aussi bas vous craignez
que le désert de notation ne dégrade de
la france je me permets de vous rappeler
que si dégradations il juge ce fut de la
part d'une seule agence de notation mais
ça n'était pas sous l'autorité de ce
gouvernement dit de l'actuelle pendant
la république mais de leurs
prédécesseurs
j'imagine qu'à l'époque les reproches
vif que vous semblez m'adresser et à
travers mon gouvernement vous avez dû
les adresser au gouvernement responsable
de cette dégradation de la notation
française
pourquoi ces taux d'intérêt sont ils bas
il y a deux raisons pour l'essence
elle la première est que les
investisseurs qui souhaitent aller dans
la zone euro dont en réalité que deux
pays suffisamment sûr pour cela
l'allemagne et la france nous
bénéficions donc d'un avantage
comparatif par rapport à d'autres pays
de la zone euro mais il ya une deuxième
raison que le fmi lui même a souligné
dans une déclaration récente c'est que
les politiques budgétaires et
financières qui sont menées jouissent
d'une crédibilité que le fonds monétaire
international reconnaît lui même
je comprends qu'elle est un peu
difficile pour des parlementaires de
l'opposition d'accorder le même crédit
qu'un organisme international peut-être
plus enclins à l'objectivité mais la
réalité est là et c'est bien le jugement
du fmi dont je vous ai fait part qui je
crois est en la matière le plus juste et
davantage que d'autres portés me
semble-t-il un peu plus par le souci du
combat politique que par celui de
l'objectivité la plus aboutie sur les
autres critiques que vous avez pu
formuler notamment sur les 35 heures je
me permettrai de vous rappeler monsieur
le sénateur que c'est en 2007 donc sous
l'empiré d'une majorité à laquelle vous
apparteniez que les 35 heures ont été
généralisées à toutes les entreprises
je veux dire aux entreprises de moins de
20 salariés pour une raison assez simple
c'est que vous aviez décidé une
politique d'heures supplémentaires que
ces heures supplémentaires se déclenche
à partir de la 35e 1 qui me paraît
d'ailleurs assez paradoxal me permets de
l'indiquer à la haute assemblée de
défendre à la fois les heures
supplémentaires et la suppression des 35
heures car si vous voulez des heures
supplémentaires il faut les 35 heures et
si vous condamnez les 35 heures il n'y a
plus d heures supplémentaires il ya donc
un choix à faire nous avons nous fait le
choix des heures supplémentaires
c'est-à-dire du travail quant aux autres
critiques concernant l' isf
les prélèvements obligatoires et le
reste je me permets de vous indiquer que
dans l'urgence il est impossible de
supprimer les emplois que vous sembliez
vouloir supprimer vous savez que c'est
en début d'année je veux dire en loi de
finances initiale que ces choses là
ce fonds est certainement pas en loi de
finances rectificative mais je vous
confirme que j'ai déjà fait pour
certains de vos collègues que l'année
prochaine il y aura bien dans l'appareil
d'état des 1300 17 suppressions de
postes et 1300 3g les opérateurs
j'espère au moins que ces éléments là
seront de nature à vous rassurer
monsieur dassault pour une minute s'il
vous plaît pas
monsieur le ministre toi même dire chers
amis bref vous fais remarquer que c'est
pas parce qu'on a fait wes politique il
ya quelques années qu'il faut continuer
à en parler aujourd'hui c'est vous
qu'êtes de pouvoir donc j'avoue de la
rangée de faire mieux et c'est vrai que
les taux d'intérêt sont bas
j'avais raison mais faut pas croire au
père noël et vont augmenter
malheureusement et je le regrette et
vont augmenter parce que nous ne tenons
pas vous ne tiendrez pas les 3% du
budget 2013
il va y avoir une augmentation et c'est
évident puisque vous n'aurez pas les
recettes nécessaires et vous aurez des
dépenses supplémentaires
vous pourrez pas y arriver alors si vous
voulez reprenant contact dans quelques
mois pour vérifier s'il va se passer
mais malheureusement ce que je vous dis
c'est pour le bien de la france c'est
ont bien l'intention du pays
et c'est pour ça que je vous dis aussi
nous sommes prêts à travailler avec vous
pour la france et son avenir
merci